new trend is sweeping theater Land and
the UK and the US blackout performances
are dedicated to black only audiences
those who are not black are asked not to
buy tickets the theater of Royal
Stratford East in London says no one's
excluded from attending their new show
Tambo and Bones promotional material
makes clear that white people aren't
wanted the production on the 19
questions as a blackout night is a
purposeful creation of an environmental
Mission all black identifying audience
back identifying audience can experience
and discuss an event in Performing Arts
free from the white gaze so does this
mean I can go if I identify as a black
man there'll be some on the woke side
who would have well they're trouble
disagreeing with that given they believe
in Limitless self-identity but it is
more important is it ever okay to
exclude audiences based on skin color
what would happen for example if it was
all the way around if this was a white
only audience well I'm joined by the
talk TV contributor Esther Krakow and
the black lives matter organizer and
activist Iman Aiden all right Imam I'm
just trying to picture what happen if I
put on a theatrical production in London
and it said it was for whites only
or people identifying as white which is
obviously a ludicrous phrase but you
would go nuts you would say that is
blatant racism segregation dragged us
Kicking and Screaming back to the dark
days of appalling bigotry you would
depends on the context right there's no
why it's only audience
no black people allowed what would you
say well I think you're perfectly right
it would be you can to racist
finding more ways to be more racist so
why is it okay this way around okay so
we have to put it into context it was
one out of the 29 shows doesn't matter
yes it does let's put it into context
pairs you want to forget about context
context is everything it is one out of
the 29 shows that we'll talk as it
towards black people and at no point did
they say people certain people are not
excluded in fact they actually sell it
they beat them on their website no one
is excluded and yet you have found
racism no no I just read the rest of
what they said it's pretty clear you are
not supposed to go if you're not black
no please consider booking other dates
right exactly I think I think the
context you're right the context is
important I think the issue here is when
it when it's talking about sort of you
know blackouts and it's trying to gather
an audience of black people that they
believe have the same experience exactly
this doesn't transpose the same way it
does in the US and the UK right a black
person in the UK could be black African
uh black British or you know like from
the Caribbean right in the US their
conversation around race is completely
different and that's why it's a problem
obviously when you bring this to the UK
people are going to be like what are you
talking about this is especially in
London can you see any Merit can you see
any Merit to it of course of course but
that's in
American why is that if you're talking
about safe spaces let's just be clear
we're talking about say space because I
think you save space look at me because
okay so you want to feel safe if I came
along no no again context we're talking
about a play that was done by black
people for black black or targeted for
black people and so one out of the again
let's just be clear because you're
clearly not getting this message it's
basically akin to the disabled Community
putting on putting on 29 shows and one
oh 29 shows about disabilities and the
one of those shows is targeted towards
the disabled community that is what it
is akin to and yet you have a problem
why is that this have you genuinely
asked yourself I have a problem between
disabilities
um disabled Jewish but when it comes to
Black my problem is that you have
already conceded that if it was the
other way around and this was a whites
only night of the theatrical cortex you
would say racist and that's my problem
is unfortunately affected by racism so
therefore it's about
no she just asked me a question so I'm
answering it we're talking about Asian
racism I think they deserve a bit of a
safe space when they're talking about
their own experiences from black people
from from all types of people that are
going to all right judgments because
it's about being free of judgments
that somebody else speaks please no I'm
going to we're going to have a safe
space where you get removed so the only
I can be heard speaking and I'll say bye
to you both I will have a one night only
only tears happily I'll see you on
Saturday I'll say bye I'll have another
one night or so only I am allowed to
speak and you're not allowed to because
of your skin color how would you like
that well that's called racing exactly
exactly my point it's not let me ask you
this What would most black friends of
yours or family think about this I mean
in other words is it something where a
lot of black people might go you know
what actually I can see some Merit to
this they would see it as an American
importation right I don't mean
necessarily a bad thing I think that it
would no yeah it would be seen it would
be seen as ridiculous but ridiculously
particularly American right because they
black people are not a monolith which we
can all agree on black people come from
various parts of the world they have
different cultures this idea that there
is a shared black experience
other than the color of our skin but I
don't but you have you you have to
accept that there are many connotations
you're adding by your own I could say
this I could say that as a black person
I faced more racism from Asian and
Middle Eastern people so I should have a
safe space from those people can you
even identify them no but that's because
that's ridiculous I don't think okay let
me interrupt that's if you've been let
me speak I don't think any form of art
should ever be exclusionary on the
grounds of skin color regardless of who
is targeted
racially equal about this yes it's
racially unequal you're saying no white
people can come it's ridiculous what's
the play about this I've heard you're
right what's the plan it doesn't matter
what it's about it does it's your issue
you want to negate context
of both of us without context you know
this and yet you tried to negotiate no I
don't know this no you go with the
context don't come with it with the
context you can't tell me what I'm
thinking exactly
that's what people like you do to me
people like me yes
racially Prejudice people like yourself
that's what you do that's why we need
safe spaces you're calling me racially
prejudiced I've done that several times
first why are you surprised why are you
saying that ignorance doesn't actually
suit you that's ignorant actually what
you just said I've just told you I'm not
racially Prejudiced and what you just
said was very offensive shouldn't be
saying that
that's what you do we've got to leave
you there thank you both very much I
appreciate it